[Applause]
thank you so much ladies and Joe I i
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
sayin the this every week against worse
than news the news stories are coming so
fast and frequently I need Dramamine to
watch the L n right I have breaking news
fatigue I do I talking to my doctor
today I said is drinking in the
afternoon right for me and he said I'm
Way ahead of you I mean it's hard to
catch you up on this week because it's
like last week never even really ended
we should start this show like all the
other HBO shows previously on previously
on as the world burns
president batshit had president Bechet
had just fired his FBI director for
investigating his Russian ties and then
met the Russians in the Oval Office to
get his next assignment
and of course pass along classified
information you know no wonder these
guys are laughing he gave it to them in
person in the Oval Office they're like
this guy is even dumber than we thought
of course you know Trump should not have
even had them in the Oval Office these
are the people hacked and meddled in our
election that's not part of the
controversy that is a fact
they meddled in the election and Trump
says wait does that Trump says well
Putin asked me to do it what am I
supposed to say come on I work for the
guy I made it what am I going to tell
the boss no he's so dumb
oh really he keeps outrightly
confessing to his crimes
Hooten told me to do it up the call me
firing he trump sends out his people to
say some [ __ ] and the next day goes
on Lester Holt and says no is because of
Russian or my idea giving the Russians
the classified intelligence stuff he
sends his people out they deny it then
he's like no yeah I did it he's like a
kid who goes to pick up his prom date
and the parents say what are your
intentions and he says I'm gonna try to
get her to give me a [ __ ] and then
okay and then this week we learned that
oh I love this James Comey kept
meticulous notes and memos on always
from including according to the coaming
memo where Trump meets would call me and
says to call me you know Flynn he's
involved with the Russians Jesus Christ
he's a good guy hope you could just let
this go hope you can let this go Comey
said you know I'm a cop right
I hope you could let this go when vice
president pence heard that he started
scratching out Vice on his business card
and then today we learned that Trump
said to the Russians during that
playdate he had with them he said in
front of note-takers to the Russians I
just fired the head of the FBI he was a
real nutjob I faced great pressure
because of Russia that's taken care of
is he trying to get impeached even
Monica Lewinsky is like wow you really
blew it the Oval Office
James Comey is the nutjob says the 70
year old man with the platinum blonde
hair and the necktie around his knees
what's the nut job he's a nut job excuse
me I gotta get back to talking to the
television by the way it's okay because
you know what all this is good news we
have a special counsel now Robert and I
I doubt that Trump will be president for
the full term maybe I don't know maybe
he might not be president by the time he
gets back from his trip you nation you a
love today out of big his big overseas
trip one huge question hangs over this
trip while he's gone who was going to
lie to Mike Pence we don't know this
because Mike Pence you've got a love
Mike ped this guy eats more [ __ ] that a
goat there is nothing this man will not
believe he can watch the [ __ ] coming
straight out of the Bulls ass and if you
tell him it's chocolate mousse he'll
repeat it
[Applause]
so yet shrubs got a big trip he's going
to Saudi Arabia Israel and the Vatican
the cradles of America's three great
religions Christianity Judaism and oil
and before I move on with the show there
is other news pretty big news that
happened this week Anthony Weiner
pleaded guilty to tweeting his dick and
Roger Ailes done between those two
stories and the horrible week Trump had
perverts got their comeuppance if there
was a movie made about this week it
would be called [ __ ] strikes back
you know yes roger ailes okay but when
somebody dies you're supposed to not say
bad things about him so let me just say
when it came to making old white
Americans more frightened and more
ill-informed nobody did it better